verte la semaine qui s'ouvre sera
marquée de main au plan judiciaire par
la reprise du procès de Patrick Dils
avec la confrontation très attendu de
Francis Holme tueur en série à la fois
témoin et suspect dans cette affaire
retour sur les premiers jours d'audience
où la déposition des enquêteurs aura été
le premier tournant de ce procès à
huclos Valérie hermit et Raymon
chapelard le face- à faceace très
attendu va pouvoir commencer
l'exinpecteur Varley qui a mené toute
l'enquête est a témoigné l'enquêteur a
toujours cru Patrick dill se coupable
depuis des années l'accusé clame son
innocence durant plusieurs heures
l'ancien policier a expliqué à la cour
son enquête qui 15 ans plus tôt l'a
amené à confondre Patrick Dils mais le
temps passé a aussi changé l'accusé face
à l'inspecteur pour la première fois
Patrick dill se seève et proteste
expliquant comment selon lui la police
l'a subtilement amené à passer des aveux
des pressions psychologiques mais
surtout un scénario du crime qui lui
aurait été suggéré et qu'il n'aurait
fait que répéter un face à face et une
déposition d'enquêteurs très diversement
ressenti par les deux parties les
dépositions qu'il vient de faire sont
très complètes alors il est normal que
le président interroge sur les
éventuelles pressions sur la
sujectibilité de Patrick Dils et cetera
mais à ce à ces questions là Monsieur
varly semble répondre d'une manière tout
à fait claire l'avocat maître rondu
semblait dire que Patrick avait été un
peu mis à mal ah j'ai pas trouvé moi
j'ai trouvé le contraire he que là
Patrick c'est vraiment bien expriméin ah
oui c'est plutôt à mon avis c'est plutôt
par était mal les audiences sont
interminables il est plus d'uneh du
matin à l'intérieur le policier puis la
juge d'instruction ni toujours toute
pression sur Patrick DS qui aura été le
plus convainquant devant la Cour le hot
qui interdit aux journalistes d'être
présent empêche définitivement
d'apporter une réponse demain ce sera
l'autre tournant de ce procès le tueur
en série Francis HM va devoir expliquer
ce qu'il faisait tout près du lieu du
crime le jour du double meurtre